hey 42 here elvis presley once asked his
limo driver
do you own this limo or do you work for
the company the driver responded that he
just worked for the company
elvis replied well you own it now
the driver's tip from elvis was
the limo so if you are not a big baller
tipping a goddamn
limo every time you leave the house then
what the hell is wrong with you
at least that's the way that
unnecessarily judgmental wait staff hope
you feel
when you leave whatever shreds of
disturbing paraphernalia
you found at the bottom of your wallet
as a tip
but seriously in north america tipping
feels like
an obligation after finishing your
delicious meal
you feel an overwhelming sense of guilt
where you not to leave a tip
and you just know that if you don't then
you'll get the steamingly judgmental
look from the waiter
as you shamefully waddle out of the
restaurant it's the same look you would
get
if you broke into their home and replace
their toothpaste with cyanide
maybe not quite the same and there's one
country that has made it their hobby to
give away free money after their
gigantic meals
america the usa is by far the world's
leader in tipping
leaving an astonishing 40 billion
dollars
of tips on restaurant tables every year
but the ironic thing is that america
imported the idea of tipping
from europe where it has since fallen
out of custom
in europe we usually tip as a
convenience
to just round up the bill because it's
simply easier to leave a two-pence tip
than to count out 49 pounds and 98 pence
in
change yes i have left a two pence tip
and no i'm not ashamed of that and
hopefully by the end of this video
you'll understand why journey back to
17th century
tudor england where taverns began
putting out jars labelled
to ensure promptitude hence the word
tip when wealthier patrons put some of
their extra money into the tip jar
the bartender would be sure to serve
them before everyone else
by the mid-18th century wealthy american
businessmen
who thought that adopting european
traditions would make them more
sophisticated
brought back the idea of tipping to
america and started to use it in their
daily lives
tipping any old poor sod from the
shoeshine boy
to their driver it wasn't long before
the railway companies and many
restaurants
caught on to this new tipping phenomenon
and of course their very first thought
was
oh boy we can use this to be even more
racist
yay and so restaurant owners and railway
operators all over america
began hiring newly freed black slaves to
work for
no wage whatsoever telling them that
they would only get paid if they
received tips
from customers so the business owners
didn't have to fork out a single penny
the public were against this idea and
the unions campaigned against
tipping but of course the extremely
wealthy railway companies and
other corporations eventually won the
battle
forever cementing tipping as a racist
foundation of the american working class
economy
and brainwashing future generations into
heavily integrating gratuity
as a social norm the old american
railroad
tipping makes people feel powerful
studies have shown
that people enjoy the notion that they
can control the level of
service they receive because they can
hold back tips
if they don't receive said service which
if you think about it it's slightly
disturbing how sociopathic
that makes most of us we all secretly
enjoy knowing that
we can stop another human from being
able to afford food
if it takes our fancy we probably
wouldn't but
it's just nice to know we can you know
but the cold
raw distasteful reality of restaurant
gratuities
is that the level of service doesn't
matter
a surprisingly large number of studies
and research papers have been done
on tipping and why we do it if you have
a free afternoon instead of your usual
self-loathing
give them a read unless of course you're
not
me and you have some things to do
but they all essentially conclude the
same result
that tipping behavior is completely
random
there is no logic to when and how much
people tip it is certainly not linked
to good service it's probably more
closely correlated to a customer's shoe
size to be honest
astonishingly receiving good or bad
service
only changes the amount people tip on
average
from between minus one percent and plus
one percent
so there you go all you wait stuff out
there
you could literally slap your customers
in the face with a ripe salmon
and the worst that would happen is
you'll receive 50 pence fewer tips
and you thought you never learnt
anything useful from this channel
waiter performance may not have any
effect on tipping
but there are things that most certainly
do have an effect
according to various studies waitresses
with larger breasts
smaller body sizes and blonde hair earn
quite a bit more from tips than those
without such features
as much as 50 percent more and that's
from both men and women
so it seems most of us mistake our local
eatery for a freaking strip club
disturbingly white servers are on
average
tipped more than black servers
regardless of the race of the customer
but not only is the average diner a
racist perv
you'll be pleased to find out that
they're also completely irrational
research has shown that we leave a
larger tip if a waiter touches us on the
arm
draws a smiley face on our bill if they
wear
red or if they squat next to our table
whilst taking our order
like a restless ape a modern habit that
i find particularly annoying the last
thing i want when trying to relax is an
overly smiley waiter squatting two
centimeters
from my actual face and recommending i
get a side of
every damn thing on the menu with that
but hey
research shows that it seems to work for
most people and if you thought
that waitress was being extra friendly
towards you because they wanted a larger
tip
or she found you unbearably attractive
then my friend you are delusional
there are a set of secret rules within
the restaurant industry that everyone
working in the food business
quickly picks up rules about who tips
and who doesn't and who tips the most
research shows that couples tip more
than groups
men tip more than women and businessmen
tip even more
waiters very quickly find out which
demographics and table sizes
leave the least and the most in tips and
they will adjust their service
accordingly waiters will automatically
pay more attention and give quicker and
friendlier service
to couples or businessmen knowing full
well that they're likely to leave larger
tips than average
and they will lower their quality of
service for large groups
i'm not saying that every waiter does
this but researchers found that the vast
majority of restaurants admit
that their weight staff practice this
very kind of favoritism towards higher
tippers
so before you even sit down your level
of service
has been predetermined just because of
how you're dressed and who you're with
just
one more reason of many not to dine out
naked
you can't blame waiters for this when
most of their income
comes from tips they are of course going
to pull every trick in the book to
milk every last penny out of the
customers
so who should we blame for everything
wrong with the
economic failure that is tipping
i'll give you two guesses your own
mother no
rasputin no why the government of
course in america there are two
variations of the minimum wage
the normal minimum wage that the
majority of jobs
receive and then the tipped minimum wage
which employers are allowed to legally
pay their employees
if they work in an industry where tips
are accepted such as servers
the hotel industry taxi drivers and just
about a thousand other professions as it
seems every year americans like to play
a game of who else can we possibly tip
hairdressers yeah cleaners yeah
drug dealer hitman why the hell not
can we all just take a moment to realize
how insane a tipped minimum wage is
employers can legally pay their
hard-working employees
less than a third of the minimum wage a
measly
2.13 per hour in most states
and then customers are expected to pay
the employees on the restaurant's behalf
let me think last time i purchased a car
i didn't sit down for a budget meeting
with the management afterwards
to decide whether i would be
contributing 20
or 25 towards the salesman's salary
but that is essentially what you're
doing every time you tip
in america so long as the tipped minimum
wage
is a thing call me a maverick
but here's a crazy idea should it not be
an
employer's responsibility to pay their
staff
a decent living wage why should a
customer who is already paying for their
meal
have to pay the staff's wages too
for an employee to legally qualify for
the tipped minimum wage
they only have to earn 30 dollars of
tips per month
to put that into perspective in america
if i tip someone 30
who doesn't usually receive tips say an
electrician
their employer can then legally cuts
their wage that month
from 7.25 per hour to 2.13
for every hour they have worked that
month
just because i decided to be a generous
sod
so by tipping in restaurants americans
are ensuring that restaurant owners
can legally pay their waiters pennies
and get away with it the problem is
every single american would have to stop
tipping overnight to solve the issue and
that's like asking bears to stop
in the woods because just 30
dollars of tips in any given month
will prevent waiters from receiving a
normal bloody wage
and that is of course never going to
happen so it is completely
understandable why people who do stick
to their morals and refuse to tip in
america
are seen as jerks and chased down the
street with cake forks and steak knives
even if their morals do make perfect
economic sense
because sadly until the laws change
tipping is essential to allow wait staff
to actually
feed themselves but even when everyone
tips it's still a really bad deal for
employees
numerous studies have shown that servers
are three times as likely to experience
poverty
than the average worker and they are
significantly more likely to make use of
welfare programs to survive
although this isn't as much of a problem
in some states
where the tipped minimum wage has been
raised the department of labor in the
u.s
investigated over 9 000 restaurants and
they found that 84 percent of
restaurants in the states
where the tipped minimum wage is 2.13
abused the tipped minimum wage to enable
them to pay their weight staff
far less than any non-tipped employee
and yes that is also accounting tips
into their wages
but there is a poor group of victims of
the tipping culture
who get a far worse deal than the wait
staff
but unlike waiters never get any
recognition
cooks as a great lover of the culinary
arts i believe that in most countries
kitchen staff are underpaid it's an
extremely demanding
and stressful job working fast-paced in
high temperatures
for long hours and a high level of skill
and training
is required but this problem of kitchen
staff being underpaid is so many times
worse in countries that have a tipping
culture
for some reason at one point in human
history i'm not sure when but some
people
in a room decided that the people who
have spent years of trading at culinary
school
and who arrive early in the morning
every morning
to begin meticulously prepping every
element of your dish
and then after many hours of misen plus
these line chefs can finally
toil away at a hot stove for many hours
to skillfully cook
and beautifully plate your delicious
dinner
those people in a room whoever they were
once decided for some ungodly reason
that these hidden heroes of the
restaurant industry
should get paid zero percent of the tips
zilch nada booger all
yet this teenager with absolutely no
training
who picks up that dish and carries it
five meters to your
table should get 100 of your tips
well that sounds a bit unfair but
unfortunately people don't give a flying
sausage because the truth is
we all tend to forget that kitchen stuff
exists
it's easy to go to a restaurant and
because you see all the pretty
waitresses
you forget that there's an army of
culinary gargoyles behind the kitchen
shutters
and they're the reason you actually went
to that restaurant
to eat their food they say waitressing
is a thankless job
but it's extremely rare that someone
gives thanks to the person
who just singed their eyebrows
flamblying your tartar tan
there are some restaurants who recognise
this disparity
and collect all the tips and then share
them out equally between the front of
house and the back of house staff
but the vast majority of restaurants
still distribute all their tips
solely to the front of house staff in
certain u.s states
statistics show that with tips wait
staff earn
significantly more than kitchen staff
and not just a dishwasher
more than the sous chef and the head
chef
in seattle for example the average
waiter earns
28 per hour with tips whereas
prep cooks and line chefs earn a
prophetic 10 to 12 dollars per hour
and the average head chef is just on 18
hour that's right the individual with
the highest amount of training
skill and expertise in the whole dawn
restaurant
still only earns 64
of what the waiters do i'm not trying to
disparage
waiters at all they do an incredibly
tough
and important job but there's an obvious
difference in expertise
between waiting and professional cooking
there has been a move in recent years by
some example
setting restaurants particularly in new
york to abolish tipping for good
some restaurants now openly state that
they no longer accept any tips and
instead add a 15 or 20
optional service charge to every bill
which is evenly distributed
between all staff including the kitchen
staff
but there's a mysterious place that has
been setting an even
better example for as long as
restaurants
have existed a place where food is the
very embodiment of its culture
a country that has been awarded more
michelin stars
than the uk and france combined
and the place where you can be served
ramen by a maid
where is this magical place you ask of
course
it is japan not only is tipping not a
part of japanese culture
but tipping in japan is actually seen as
an insult
it's funny if you want a waitress to
spit in your food
in north america you forget to tip
whereas in japan you'd have to do the
complete opposite and
actually tip to get some survival
revenge
not that the ultra polite japanese would
ever stoop
that low if you did insult a japanese
chef the worst that would probably
happen
is they would just give you a slightly
less enthusiastic
bow why is tipping in japan so insulting
because it is viewed by japanese people
as
charity rather than a reward for good
service
it can be seen as you implying that the
restaurant isn't doing
well enough to pay their workers the
proper salary it's also construed that
you may be marking them
on their performance and japanese
restaurant workers
really don't like that because they
always believe that they are giving 100
effort in japanese culture people don't
just go to work and work tirelessly for
money
to buy more sushi and manga they also do
it
for honor a sense of honor for one's
boss for the workplace and more
importantly
for the customers is a deeply held moral
in japan so if a japanese waiter
knowingly gave a customer bad service
then their honor would be impeached upon
which is punishment enough upon itself
a service charge is already included in
the price of your meal in most
restaurants in japan
in the form of a seating charge called
otoshi
literally meaning to pass it's a small
fee to pay for your table in the
restaurant
and as a way to indirectly pay for
service
taking the place of what tips would do
in the western world
but the nice thing about the atochi fee
over tipping
is that you actually get something in
return
for your money and no it's not those
wooden chopsticks that you impatiently
snap apart as soon as you sit down
as a thank you for paying the seating
fee you get a small plate
of food as soon as you are seated
something to nibble upon whilst reading
the menu
kind of like an amused boot it's usually
a tasty little morsel such as
endonami beans or some seafood the thief
of the otashi is automatically added to
your bill
and then it's out of the way forgotten
about you could enjoy your meal
say thank you and leave instead of
having to do mathematics after your meal
to work out a tip
and if you're in a group work out how to
split that tip
up just creating awkwardness
because no doubt everyone will want to
tip a different amount
and you can guarantee that there will be
one member of the group who's gotten so
magnificently trollied
that they already put their tip into
some unfortunate waitress's garments
or maybe i've just been hanging out with
the wrong sort of people
in fact tipping isn't done across the
whole of asia
it's more of a western well to be more
specific north american phenomena
in europe waiters are paid living wages
the same as any other profession
and on the continent service charges are
commonly added to bills
to replace tips similar to the japanese
atashi system
in italy for example you are often given
complementary bread or even a beverage
to start your meal
as part of the service charge the
italians call this a caperto
or cervizio there is just nothing
good about tipping in every aspect it is
futile
unfair it promotes discrimination it
creates
awkwardness for everyone involved and
the end result is customers pay more
and staff earn less it's about time we
take a lesson from asia
and abolish this archaic practice of
automatic tipping once and for all
of course there's nothing wrong with
tipping on occasion if a particular
person has gone out of their way
to make your night truly special and
memorable
even i tip in those circumstances just
for those of you who now think i'm the
most tight-fitted person
in all of nato but tipping automatically
in the words of mr pink is for the birds
thanks for watching if this video has
served you well then consider leaving a
tip
on patreon to help out the channel but
if it's any less than 20
i will find you and i will thank you
because
seriously i'm incredibly grateful